EVENA PRIVATE STIGATO TRACK
DEMOCRATIC CSMAN ERIC
SWD HI
IMRESSMAN
BROOKSCCOUNTAB HIS LEGED ROLE I
AND KICKING ASS. TRUMPPPORTERS
SWALWELL'S LEL  THE SERVINGLEPW
HE SAYS  SNEAKED INTO HIS
E AND ACCOSTED HIS WIFE.N'T CORT
AISWALWELL'S
ARLIER PROCESSVER DID NO
INTO T BE AND THE
BROOKS KNOW THAT.
YESTERDAY G
PROCESS SERVER WHO WAS
SUONT OF THE
IN THE MORNING AND S
S. BROOKS DRIV
APPARENTLY SG
PAIND END OF T
REATD WA TOOF E CAME BK WHEN
ABLE TO SERVE HER.
AND MO BROOKS ISTHE
CA.  FORMER R  NOW TO DISS
DISCUSS ISTHAT CONGRESSMAN BROO
HAPPENS
>> H ANSR
INT, HIS WILL  THE ALLEGATIONS
THE COMPIN  DENIALS BUT PRESUMAO
FACTS AS WELL.
ANTH MOTIONSANDISCOVERY.
THAT'S REALLY THE BIG TICKET
ITEM HE,S E I
IN EXACTLYAL CASE IN THE  DISCO
WHAT HAPNEUAF BROOKS FEELS HE W
IMLY SERVED ISANYTHI HE N  LEGA
JURISDICTION OVER HIM OR THE
SE GNGO SUCCEED.TH
WHERE THE HEAR
HE CAN TRY TO MAKE TT MOTION TH
WSUCCEED.
>> T ISSUE OET
RIE OKS'N EY IF E'S
T IN THE LAWSUIT
THBOUT
WHO YOU CAN SERVE. PAND THERE'S
BU THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO SERVE THE  Y EVY
OUTHE
LAUIE KNOW
TATIVE BOKBECAUSE HEKED ABOUT IT
PUBLICLY, THEN THE
EVVE SCEE COURAV
WAIVED SERVICE
LLLLINES
PACTEIDSKS HIDING
THEYHAVESW TLAINT.
>> HOW STRONG ISLWELL'S CORE>>
BL.T
THOUGH, SO THE ISSUE OHER  ACTU
CASE THAN JUST THEIR WORDST FOVO
SO ALD SAY
ITHAIT IS A
.
IT'S N ANAL  HAVE TO PROVEONON
.CONVIN HAT IT
THRA
EVIDENCEUGGEST HE WAS
>> H L O?